I made a rookie homeschool mistake
I forgot to lesson plan this weekend and start our Monday off with no plan
it's not an ideal way to start the week
but also not the end of the world
while the kids did morning work
I got my stuff together luckily
I do look ahead so I had a good idea what we were gonna do today
I just didn't have everything prepared
so I had to wait honestly
sometimes those lessons work out better than the ones I have fully prepared
so for the last week I've been working on the ng confident team with math
I just have to say I am struggling
I have the hardest time making the ng sound by itself
I don't know how to do it without putting too much emphasis on the G
but when you use it in ng ng on your own
you don't over emphasize the G
I am just on the struggle bus
I need someone to teach me how to make the ng sound
and because I just can't do it
I taught it as a word family
to make matters worse Maverick has a little country twang to it
and he never says the G at the end of a word
so I'm over emphasizing and he's skipping it
all together we are just the dynamic duo over here